so today me and Dahlia are going to talk
about how to detect normal anomalies in
Twitter data it's a little bit about us
so Delia was a PhD in natural language
processing and machine learning and I
did the master in statistics couple of
years ago so the company we work for is
called bear with me this this is
happening we don't know why but it comes
back quite quickly there yeah then the
company work for is called gnosis and is
a social intelligence company provide
yeah okay can you hear me yeah so it's a
social intelligence company which
analyzes Twitter data so why do we want
to analyze to that data well in recent
years social media become quite popular
and people talk in a lot on social media
and they're also become an alternative
source of news of information so people
wants to know what's going on and the
one to know what's the crowd view of you
know of what being told on Twitter so I
should a little bit what what what one
of our products looks like so we say
it's impossible to keep track of what
was going on on twitter if you just use
Twitter on his own so what we do is to
run algorithms that understand what
what's actually relevant among the twist
that that are generated and we classify
them into into I mean with we divide
them into into bucket and say well if
the tweets is talking about Apple the
company Apple then we we put it in these
in this stream here so we're on some
classification and it's an equation
where rhythms that manages to identify
twist for a specific company but we can
also do we also do it for four themes or
events like the terrorism or stuff like
that and if you if you go
can have another view of what's being
told about Apple or other things like
Santander and and things like that it is
a bit of analytics that we also do so
the important thing is that people wants
to be wants to be up to date with
respect to news and Twitter is an
alternative source of of news so what so
what what do we do it there you go again
anyway what do we do at nose is so in
order to do all of this we develop
algorithms about named entity
recognition or disambiguation link is
this means that when when there are
tweets about Apple we need to understand
if Apple is the company or the fruit
what else we need to link different
things like I don't know tweets about
Tim Cook to to the company Apple its
absolute to the same to the same concept
we also do event detection so important
to get so people wants to know when
there is an event like for instance when
two companies are merging or when when a
company is acquiring another one and
often twitter is the source of these of
these news on when there is a breaking
news it first breaks on Twitter and this
way way faster than traditional news
sources we also do some social network
analysis and sentiment analysis but what
we're going to talk to you what we are
going to tell you about today is anomaly
detection and novelty detection so why
why we're giving this to us so what you
really wanted to do was to detect novel
anomalies in Twitter data so what does
that mean it means that our users want
to be alerted quite quite quickly
promptly when there is a you know some
some anomalies in the in the social
activity around maybe a company or an
event this means that we want to detect
stuff that are not previously seen so
they are not up there are novel
and somehow deviates from what is
standard was it what is expected and all
of these concerns social activity this
means like the volume of tweets that we
see about a specific company as you know
is not standard is not expected so this
means that the conversation spikes up
and suddenly it gets viral so people
start talking about it and at this so
why people want to talk about that wants
to know about it well because most of
the time these links to an event that
has happened or is about to happen so
here I'll show you a little a little
chart which is about the daily tweet
volume 44 Volkswagen so all the twists
that we think that that our systems
detect us as a containing a relevant
content God you know processed and this
is the daily daily volume for for a
couple of weeks back in September so
what we see is that like we went like
conversation was quiet for for a few
days but then on the intent of
September's was a clear spike in the
volume of tweets being created and
published by users and if you second a
volume is the is the number of tweets
that we that belongs to the post Fagin
stream so what we identify as being
linked to two boss wagon right it
because this is an example about
forceful so that's a daily debut so each
bar is the volume for that day and what
we see on the team is this bike here
which if you ever closer look at the
stop price well we see that on dating
something happened and the stop price in
dropped massively what was that about
well on that day on some some user
tweeted about the emission standards
that then involved was firing that was
Nina's before traditional news sources
so sometimes happen that on twitter news
get published earlier than traditional
than in traditional news agency so you
know if you are an investor or if you
got money invested in in both bargain
that you probably want to know about
about events happening around this
company or you know if you are ik trader
you want to maybe show this company that
like maybe twenty thirty percent return
out of it right so that's pretty that's
pretty useful for for people who cares
about companies and things like that so
let's have a look at how we build this
detection system so as I said at the
beginning at the starting point is the
universe of tweets but we cannot we
cannot deal with with a lot i'm right
there is a lot of noise there is a lot
of your relevant information being
shared on Twitter so no SI system this
with all of these these problems so we
process we prep process tweets we run
you know classification and other
algorithms to do only to filter tweets
to correctly identify to which company
these treaties talking about and after
we got a bunch of them we give it to to
the anomaly that detection service so
this is responsible to get these tweets
look at some some volume some mystery
about the tweets volume for for this
company here and give an answer which is
yes we are approaching an animal's
pillars or we are in into in an
anomalous situation this output is then
passed to the novelty detection service
which day is going to talk about in a
minute which again look at some you know
some the tweets published in the past
about what's buggin and the tax if the
anomalous situation is actually novel so
it's talk about something that has never
happened in the past so people don't
want I'm sorry people don't want to be
alerted by start
that has already happened you know
yesterday or a few hours before they
want to be alerted promptly but
something something new and the answer
and the final output of this this
pipeline is a easy it's quite summary of
what's going on on Twitter which is a
single tweet which is the most
representative of this anomalous
situation right so which are the main
challenges of these of this detection of
the volume Adam anomaly detection system
well we as I said we wanted to alert
users promptly and if you have a look at
these which is another season under
chart and which is here today so from
the beginning of the year till till a
couple of days ago we see well we want I
mean we want to identify these spikes
but we need to be careful right so in
this period here we can see that the
conversation was was not so high we got
few spikes but what we really want is to
is to get those which are unexpected
right so we don't want to to get for
instance this sort of we don't want to
be to alert people for this sort of
spice because something has already
happened right how do you how do how do
you know that right so how do you avoid
false anomalies and how do you get them
to get the good one in a fast way quick
way so in order to answer this question
we need to mean to define our program
right so we need to define the variable
to measure so we need to understand why
so what was the feature of the
characteristic of the data that makes it
anomalous so it can be in honor to it
you got many information the location
the time anything so what what makes the
social activity anomalous so that's
that's one question that you need to ask
yourself and also how do you establish
if what you observed is unexpected so
you need to give to measure
for for that and approach that we took
and is by the way applicable to two
other two other situations is right we
we count the number of tweets given a
fixed time window so we said okay let's
let's let's let's consider I don't know
ten minutes on armor whatever and we
count the tweet published during this
period and then to establish the
anomalous nature of of this period we
predict the what we expect to be the
number of twists for for that period and
then we use this prediction to give a
measure of the unexpectedness of the of
the measure and and this is quite
important I mean this this is applicable
to any any sort of data with concerns
events happening in time so as long as
we have an event which which is defined
at some point in time we can then use
this approach which it straightforward
is simple and this easy to to explain to
people right so let's less than less
than try to model this this this number
of twists as come seen in time right so
if we so the thing to do is to model the
tweets right for this for let's say the
stream concerning was for again so what
we can do is to take a basic approach
and say alright the we assume that the
volume is quite static which is you know
which is not idea because we we can see
we got some seasonal behavior here so
every week people talk more publish more
to learn during weekdays and then the
conversation one goes quiet during the
weekend especially if we are talking
about like financi finance related or
internal news and so we don't want to
use a static volume right if we take if
we if we consider the average volume for
this period is clearly not indicative of
of what's going on in general so you
guys like pigs like these or this one
which have got the same volume but that
clearly in two different context so what
we want is a dynamic rate which changes
over time and it was a sort of includes
it has got some sort of memory of what
happened in the in the recent past so
what what's the natural way to do that
well if we got if we have events
happening in time there is the natural
way to do that to model dam is using a
Poisson process I and this have got that
has got a very simple explanation and
you know it is quite straightforward
sorry if we take the expected number of
tweets or events because that's general
occurring until certain time then this
is directing is proportional to the to
the rate at which these events happening
and the time that has passed till the
beginning so the parameter of this
process is the right using our cases the
tweet right and we can then have a nice
explanation of what what we expect
what's the expected value for this for
this process and what's very very handy
is also having a regression model that
manages to model these this expected
number of tweets or events as a linear
combination of stuff that we know about
this about this period or or about these
tweets so so forward logarithm of this
rate is a linear combination of
predictors characteristic of the data
and some coefficients that we estimate
running the derogation model so so what
was the next question then well let's
let's pick some predictors for for the
for the tweet right and our approach or
what what I show you here is how to
select them are to be as simple
I mean out to be as simple as possible
and include all these designs the effect
and memory context that i told you about
already so one some of them can be you
know can involve the day of the week in
with that we are analyzing the hour of
the day maybe if we are in on a larger
scale include even the month of the year
but any anything that concerns seasonal
seasonal behavior can be included in
this model as well as recent behavior
that can be you know twit published in
the previous time window to 10 minutes
earlier or twist published until this
point a time of the day or month or
yesterday anything you can include other
variables the model is flexible you just
add them as predictors and and there's
no you don't add much complexity to the
model itself but so it did ok so this
this is this is the approach to predict
the variable to predict the tweet right
but what we want you to do at the
beginning was to detect the anomaly so
we don't want to cooperate a model that
that perfectly fits the data and do all
these of thing but we need to detect the
nominee and measure give a measure of
how expected was discount of of tweets
and how we do that well we can simply
take a probabilistic approach which says
right I have a prediction for the tweet
right I calculate the probability that I
see a number of tweets which is greater
than the one so what was the probability
of seeing more tweets than what I've
seen so far well if this has got a very
low probability and then you set this
threshold choosing the threshold it's
called it alpha then if the probability
of this event happening is quite low
than so well this is unlikely given my
my prediction right and then can you can
establish with this probabilistic
framework announcer it says yes it's the
period is anomalous so we are seeing an
anomalous number number of tweets and
the cool thing about this approach is
that and this is why i wanted to show to
you is that it's super timely so we we
can even predict the twitter it in
advance so there is nothing that stops
us from predicting it at the beginning
of the of the period so we are just
taking into account variables concerning
the day of the month or the day of the
week the time said it's a is everything
is known in advance it sounds supervisor
you don't need to don't need annotations
so the beginning we didn't actually know
what what an anomaly was because it's
not clear right so it can be about
anything can be about a scandal
happening or other other things or you
know i'm CEO stepping down you don't you
don't you don't need to you don't need
to provide annotations for that the
other thing is that it adapts to
different times case so if you are
detecting events happening quite fast
like tweet publishing published or
events which are happens in a larger
time frame then you can adopt this model
so it can be like stuff like a sensor
with the text light or something passes
through or you know email requests to
the server anything any event that
happens in time it can it can include
more predictors you're free to add more
of them it doesn't that hurt the the
complexity of the model and i told you
about the poisson distribution but you
can use different different families
different distribution from you sir you
can use internal felices here say that
one of the one of the disadvantages of
this approach of these of using exactly
the Poisson model is that some sometimes
the data are over dispersed which means
that the variances is not I mean it's
they got high variance and the Poisson
model doesn't doesn't allow you to to
model the variance with the different
parameters so the parameters which is
the same as the beam so you might want
to use a negative binomial one which
gives you more flexibility another thing
another disadvantage is that when you
have events which are rare most of the
time in these time windows you have no
event so 0 which kind of affects your
your prediction so what you might want
to do is to user 0 inflated for song
which models the basically the number of
times that the event happens so the
event happens yes or no and then after
that you put a Poisson on it with modest
number of events during this time window
and another thing is that these just
looks at the volume of tweets and the
time at which they are published there
is no way to to understand if the
anomaly is genuine so it's not driven by
spam or it's somehow expected which can
be unused at that is that people know is
coming out like product release or stuff
but all but this is a starting point
this is always we start and we say write
this volume here is an understand there
are all sorts of other algorithms that
comes after that and can help you
detecting the iftar normally is genuine
or not and that's what they'll is going
to tell about yeah
Thanks okay so mighty I explained how we
obtain these anomalous periods now what
I'm going to tell you talk to you about
is novelty detection so the output of
the pipeline that he just explained is a
period in which we have a number of
tweets which the algorithm considers to
be anomalous now the question is okay we
do not want to alert the person if this
information has been previously seen we
do not want to alert a person for every
single tweet in that time period so we
extended this pipeline and edit a
novelty detector system that does just
that it selects from this time period a
tweet that is actually important
relevant and it is also novel so give it
an anomaly period identify which of the
twist is novel and we do this by
starting from an observation that these
tweets tends to cluster in what we call
stories and for example the false flag
and story with the emission scandal is
is one such one such example so we
redefine the problem and say given an
anomaly period find me those tweets
which are not part of a previously seen
story so for example here in for false
wagon you see that there it starts
already with the epa's issues notice at
353 so the second tweet from below but
and then afterwards there will be a
period in which there will be multiple
tweets reiterating the same story what
are the challenges so first of all we
are working in a streaming setting this
means that each tweet needs to be
processed in a bound space and
I'm now the bound space means that we
have constant amount of stories in
memory and the bound time means that we
need an algorithm that can actually
provide an output in a timely manner
with Charles locality sensitivity
hashing for that another thing to
consider is how much history is it
required in order to decide if a
treatise novel or not so how much time
in the in the past do we need to go in
order to make a good decision and one
more thing is that stories can be
reoccurring so you can have let's say
the EPA scandal for false wagon can
start in September then for a certain
amount of time the situation is quiet
and then let's say in December or
January it spice again because there's
additional information some people get
there are some repercussions of the
scandal I hope so you cannot hear me
okay yeah okay
yeah so the paper that we were looking
at ok so the paper that that was really
interesting for us was shooting first
story detection with application to
Twitter so Sasha Petra which had a very
interesting approach to solving this
problem and the idea of the paper that
we also took was ok we have locality
sensitivity hashing it's a very nice
algorithm and is going to give us
information about what we have seen in
the past and is novel but additionally
to that we have to pay attention because
locality sensitivity hashing is not
particularly good at showing us the
tweets that are different from what
we've seen before so in locality
sensitivity hashing you have you find an
approximate nearest neighbor it is
defined as an approximate nearest
neighbor task you hash each tweet into a
bucket to maximize the probability of
collision for the tweets which are close
and you also have a measure of distance
for for your tweets now the thing is
that it works very well if you are going
to have a tweet that has been seen
before and is in your in your locality
sensitivity action index history however
if that tweet is quite distant from the
twist that you have seen before it's not
going to be able to tell you that that
tweet is already seen so what we did was
additionally to the locality sensitive
reaction index we also added another
index
where we keep the most recent tweet and
then whenever we identify a tweet that
is novel according to our historical
index we ask our most recent tweet index
is that treat act is that tweet actually
novel so the novelty flow looks as
follows we have an incoming tweet we ask
ourselves is this tweet in the locality
sensitive hashing index if it is then
the tweet is not novel and if not we are
going to look it up in the inverted
index if the inverted index tells us
that it is actually novel to it then we
are going to alert the system and if not
we have a confirmation that the tweet is
not normal so to sum up we have two main
parts of the system one part generates
our anomaly period and for that we've
used a generic anomaly detection system
which can be applied to different
problems it is easily understandable
fast to train and it also provides
prediction in a in a fast manner and it
works well in a streaming pipeline for
the second part the novelty detection
part we use a two-step approach we
obtain fast lookup using locust and
video action and we also perform an
additional look up in order to confirm
that our tweet is actually novel okay so
thank you and if you have any questions
say yeah so the question was their
aggression that I used if the if the
variables to some of the predictor
predictors are correlated or not so the
thing is that I used categorical
variables so it means that the hour of
the day so for some you divide the data
into buckets again basically say you
have you consider one so you can see
that the coefficient for one variable
only at the time so for instance if you
have hours and you only consider if it's
six o'clock if that tweet comes in the
period between six and seven o'clock
then you only consider that coefficient
that she's not it's not a problem oh by
the way here was not look at least a
Russian but reduction right so that one
i call it like a break point detection
algorithm because what it was what he
did was to calculate the medians between
periods and check if the medians was
like you know stepping up or down from
what yeah package yeah the our packaging
yeah and that was more like we couldn't
use it so with this one you can set the
time window and can be super quick
detecting it's very sensible this one
with the package heed of twitter twitter
twitter elise i wasn't able to do that
as much sort of to get the dynamics as
quick as with this one so it was more on
a lot you can use it on larger
transplant which works quite well and
the other thing was that with with these
you have a better understanding of
what's the probability of this event
happening because you got a probability
promote behind it and you can and the
other the other cool thing about this is
that there is a clear link between the
bayesian approach and the frequent a
stigma frequentist one this is this one
because the regression in the two places
are the same and gives the same result
so you can actually estimate the
probability of these are normally
happening or not which we you couldn't
do with that one
there would seem to be two components
that are a little bit missing from this
system one is a sense of reputation
which is usually done by analyzing the
social graph the second one would be a
sense of keyword waiting which may
knowledge that no all keywords are
equally financial definitely so what
what so what I try to tell you when I
showed that pipeline is that all these
things are done by other algorithms so
our company has got some user analysis
that was the social network analysis
that we that we do and we also give
scores to each tweet which it is a
relevance code which says right this is
financially relevant and is based on
keyword and another another thing so
these two pieces were just looking at
the volume so my part didn't actually
look at the text but the input of it was
only were like were only starts off to
eat which are relevant and whiskey in
our case the novelty algorithm actually
just need to know which tweet is normal
and not not about this content but yeah
there are definitely due to problems
which we solve and our you know they are
present in Twitter data yeah
so again yeah
so at the beginning I was like trying to
to to run different modest or the
negative binomial one other families in
order to get the best fit out of it but
actually is not what we really want what
we want is to detect anomalies she's not
like to get the best fitting algorithm
as i said like i don't measure the
prediction I measured the outcome of the
detection which says so if if my
algorithm text well detects well anomaly
is then it does the job right so it's
it's about getting the anomaly it's not
getting the prediction right yeah but
yeah but we need to detect the spikes
right we done for instance into the type
when the conversation goes down yeah but
it's not supervise that this so you
cannot you first need I mean if you know
already what's anomalous then run
classification I stuff like that but we
didn't know what was anomalous or not
yes yeah yeah yeah but it is something
that happens with time you know you need
to wait and annotate things yeah so so
this would be okay just look at the
previous acceleration forget about any
regression and do these things yes but
it doesn't force performs as well as as
this one so I've tried already using
just a Poisson model the Poisson
distribution to get the probability of
being anomalous if that's what you're
saying right you take the previous count
you use a t-test parameter and check the
p-value for the current count at this by
the way this doesn't doesn't include any
any concept about time which is
seasonality is the main aspect of of
this thing because if something happens
at four in the morning on a sunday night
then that's that people wants to know
about it that's pretty anomalous
good one what the user profile yeah yeah
as I said yeah so we have we have a user
ranking system with just this thing and
actually gives a it's all right these
users are important let's say for these
sort of assets rather than for others
and I do audio track would you intro
that's a desert so while we analyze the
social graph and Iran and users which
are either both or the information that
they
at this level it's not about relating
the user to what kind of topic how can
you but this is not part so what we
showed here is not the entire system in
order to be able to alert users so
financial professionals definitely there
are parts of the system that need to
take into account how credible is the
user are practically circus of
information here we were only talking
about how to detect when a treat what
kind of tweets are anomalous and then
given that these tweets are anomalies
which of these are normal street did we
see before or not so this is all this is
a very small subset of the rectum but
you arrive definitely definitely the
source of the information is a definite
input that you did take into account
otherwise you are going to show
otherwise this system is going to show a
lot of spammy information because if you
have a user or a bunch of users that
tweet the save the exact same tweet a
million times this this system is going
to detect it even if you're going to be
alerted all you want
yes how do you protect your users
micro-cap markets for years where we
spread a rumor mer let's let the rumor
mill run with it and make make money of
the back day traders who are hoping for
the best what's a three-question but we
don't we don't write ourselves no but
your users have a very real issues that
Twitter guys being used to get market
yeah but that's why all these relevant I
got items or stop or anything to the
user comes into the game we provide
course we provide what we think about
the user we say okay this is this is
highly practical it's a source I got
some credibility I just want to be clear
of that what you're saying there's some
way but they're connected solve the
problem rent yeah the way that schemes
work is that they if they're basically
spear phishing schemes that are I
convince reputable users into Twitter
community to retweet a event as it were
bad information yeah yeah okay I give
you my answer yeah which is that's
that's enough to have your own
like people if the Potala mystery twins
some false information that i tweeted
you can do anytime
was was him decided
I don't know if you want you any other
answer I think is yeah from my point of
view I think the answer is we give a
score to the users and this score is
adapted so if we find out later on that
this user disseminated wrong information
then we can adapt and we can change the
information that we assign so this score
now if this happens let's say that I
there is a user it puts out certain
erroneous information the system is
going to detect it first time that
inside however we can rectify you can
think of it like an online learning
system using active learning ok let's
thanks Nellie and Matty again